whose skies smiling at me nothing but
blue skies
violet Klaus and sunny were intelligent
children most everything that happened
to them was rife with misfortune and
despair your parents have perished in a
terrible fire perished means killed we
know what perished means hello hello
hello children I am Count Olaf your new
Guardian you know what this is it looks
like a list wrong it's a list a list of
chores we know you're just trying to
steal a parents fortune we have to get
out of this wretched place go back to
the house where it's safe and strangers
can't get you strangers where the boodle
their children will be destroyed what
hmm
when the sand runs out that fortune is
mine I didn't realize the Sun went so
quickly I bought it online you're gonna
need to flip it a couple of times your
parents and I we used to develop our own
secret codes
our parents developed secret codes in my
library you will find all the answers
that you need let's get to work
something strange is going on
what's that something my parents had it
looks like the tattoo Count Olaf has on
his ankle
my name is captain chefs manager uli
Count Olaf in disguise aren't you smart
wherever you go I will hunt you down why
do you hate us so much because it's fun
we are setting out on a very top secret
expedition what do you say Baudelaires
are you in
I'm taking you to prison well good luck
with that I'm armed
so my child's play hmm adorable hmm it's
a harpoon gun
you